un match serré avec du suspense la
finale du tournoi future de plaisir a
tenu toutes ses promesses
après un premier acte serré c'est le
néerlandais igor sijsling 310e mondiale
qui remporte le set 7 6 face aux
français yoann tâte lot 5 112e mondial
le deuxième set est remporté par le
tricolore 6 3 mais c'est finalement le
joueur d'amsterdam qui remporte le
tournoi à 7 6 dans le dernier set en
2h45 de jouer le top mais je suis très
heureux ce fut un match difficile
c'est un joueur très jeune qui fut très
bien on était vraiment proche sur cette
rencontre
chaque point était serré seulement
quelques points ont décidé de ce match
je suis très heureux à propos de ça ap
bagdad
c'est une finale qui a été très disputée
bon évidemment vous savez il ya toujours
dans une finale des quelques points
un ou deux voire trois points qui sont
déterminants dans un match de chez type
là ce que les joueurs sont très proches
les uns des autres
donc voilà mais je pense qu'on a vu de
très beaux points que le tennis de haut
niveau et est au rendez vous encore à
plaisir cette année la troisième plus
grosse compétition de tennis d'île de
france derrière roland garros et bercy a
failli ne pas se disputer à cause du coc
u19
les organisateurs ont décidé de le
maintenir avec des conditions sanitaires
drastiques avec 32 joueurs dans le
plateau final
au niveau national il y avait très peu
de tournois justement professionnels
notamment ses premiers tournois futures
ou les joueurs les jeunes joueurs
professionnels chercher à avoir des
points il y avait pratiquement est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure lors de la
remise des prix c'est que je réside en
charge nano
et une courage vraiment d'organiser
l'auto mois le tournoi de tennis de
plaisir devrait être de nouveau
organiser l'année prochaine igor
sijsling devrait revenir pour défendre
son titre